China plant wirklich gigantisch es will die grösste wettermaschine der welt bauen damit soll die austrocknung von tibet verhindert werden
Durch den klimawandel droht die region nämlich zu verstecken china wird es dort jetzt
Künstlich regnen lassen wie sie das machen und was die folgen sind
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen aus new york
15 grad an den weihnachtstagen und dafür - gerade an ostern das wetter macht was es will
Aber so ganz machtlos sind wir gar nicht
im gegenteil wir menschen können tatsächlich das wetter beeinflussen mit silberjodid
Dämpfte wolken beispielsweise die lassen es künstlich regnen und genau das hat jetzt china. Im großen stil vor
Im ganz großen stil aber wie funktioniert das
meistens werden dafür motor flüge eingesetzt die über oder
unter den wolken fliegen sie strahlen eine aceton lösung in die wolken mit die mit silberjodid
versetzt sind der situation
sorgt dafür dass wasser anziehende salze frei werden und genau die haben dann
riesige wolken zufolge denn sie verbinden sich mit dem wasser position vieler kleinerer wurden soeben einer großen weil diese dann so schwer ist
Sinkt sie und löst sich auf es regnet das silberjodid funktioniert quasi als kondensationskeime
Das den wasserdampf dazu bringt ab zu regnen auf natürlichen wegen funktioniert das übrigens ähnlich weil eben nicht
ausgelöst silberjodid sondern beispielsweise durch pollen ruß oder
staubpartikel anstatt silber juli können auch trockenes oder flüssiger stickstoff als
Regen auslöser fungieren und diese methode ist tatsächlich weiter verbreitet als man vielleicht denkt
Nicht nur in china und russland wird sie eingesetzt sondern auch hier bei uns in deutschland und das nicht weil man
Den so entstehenden regen so schätzt sondern eher um schlimmeres zu verhindern hage und
schlimme unwetter nämlich die idee dahinter die wolken werden künstlich dazu gebracht ab zu regnen bevor sich etwas schlimmeres
zusammenbraut die bauern bezahlen und organisieren das dann auf eigene faust in deutschland geht das bei der wetterbeeinflussung
hauptsächlich darum unwetter zu vermeiden in anderen ländern wird das anders gehandhabt hier wird zum besonderen ereignissen gerne auch
mal sonnenschein
künstlich erzeugt beispielsweise in russland bei der militärparade zum sieg über
Nazi-deutschland, im vergangenen jahr die wettervorhersagen waren miserabel doch die russische luftwaffe ist bekannt dafür dass sie
wolken impft damit diese dann schon einige zeit vorher und einige kilometer vor dem ort des geschehens
Abregnen sonne pur war zwar nicht das ergebnis aber immerhin gab es auch keine ähnlich 2008 in china bei der eröffnung der olympischen spiele
absolut klares wetter eigentlich waren schwere unwetter vorhergesagt aber 1000 raketen
behinderten diese und schossen außerhalb der stadt in den wolken fragen der nehme doch was macht das mit der umwelt
Im gefahrstoffe informationssystemen der gesetzlichen unfallversicherung ist sehr periode mit achtung gekennzeichnet die freisetzung solle vermieden werden
Doch dadurch dass sie nur in sehr kleinen konzentrationen freigesetzt wird um regen
Zu vermeiden halten es viele expertinnen und experten für umständlich demnach seien keine negativen folgen für die umwelt zu erwarten
und auch nach der eu
gefahrstoff richtlinie dient als ungefährlich setzte
Im regen sei es kaum
nachweisbar weil die verdünnung sehr stark ist dennoch haben die vereinten nationen schon sehr früh auf diese technik reagiert und bereits
1977 wurde die konvention namens
Entwarf er in kämpfe unterzeichnet die beteiligten 77 staaten
haben dort beteuert dass sie die umwelt niemals in einem konflikt gezielt schädigen werden
Die un konvention ist tatsächlich eine reaktion auf den massenhaften einsatz
der silberjodid methode zur wetterbeeinflussung in den 50er und 60er jahren sie untersagt ist das wetter zur
Kriegsführung oder anderen militärischen zwecken zu manipulieren auch deutschland hat die konvention unterzeichnet
Dabei ist die ganze methoden nicht mehr wissenschaftlich belegt ja richtig denn tatsächlich gibt es keinerlei
statistische studien die belegen dass dieser wolken beschuss wirkt
Denn kaum etwas ist so komplex wie das wetter und das klima nicht nur der wind sondern auch die beschaffenheit der volkan
wolken ändern sich andauernd die man kann zeigen ob es an der jeweiligen
Wolken impfungen lag dass es nicht geregnet hat vielleicht hätte es ja auch ohne impfung nicht geregnet
allerdings
Es gibt auch einige zeichen dafür dass es wirklich funktioniert dani expertinnen und experten sind der meinung dass ein paar flugzeugen mit silberjodid
Beginnt, im gepäck kaum etwas. Gegen die gewaltige energie einer wolke ausrichten können vor allem sei kaum möglich
zum richtigen zeitpunkt an genau der richtigen stelle zu impfen davon ausgeht dass eine wolke beispielsweise
500.000 tonnen flüssiges wasser erhält bräuchte man unfassbar viel energie
Um diese dicke wolke verdunsten, zu lassen nämlich in etwa die energie von 14
Nagasaki atombomben ja allerdings es ist ja auch nur das sind ja nur kondensationskeime
Also, sie müssen eigentlich nicht die energie einsetzen sondern einfach nur ein paar
kondensation punkte setzt china setzt zwar kein atombomben aber immerhin unfassliche
10.000 öfen sie werden überall in tibet aufgestellt sie verdampfen silberjodid so
Dass es durch aufwände in die wolken getragen wird angeblich sollen diese öfen über monate ohne wartung arbeiten
So soll es dauerhaft
Zum eintrag von silberjodid in die wolken über dem bett kommen und sie sollen dort abregnen ob das funktioniert
Ob es wirklich, so eine schlaue idee ist fossile brennstoffe dazu. Zu verwenden um die folgen des klimawandels aufzuhalten
das wird die zukunft zeigt das ist in jedem fall das erste
Größere geo engineering project weltweit wir dürfen gespannt sein wenn er als erstes neues zum
thema geoengineering zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
Oder wir können dort auch mit den anderen messengern wie instagram facebook messenger oder telekom euch anmelden
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert ihr könnte und direkt über mich in redaktion von finck so mitmachen und mitbestimmen was sie über kriegs- und passiert und zur begrüßung
gibt es noch ein kleines bulli einfach hier draufklicken natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter dafür auch. Draufklicken mit rettet uns geoengineering
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran